on paie un parmi les plus chers a pris
pour les services cellulaires et ses
risques internet à travers le monde
les prix élevés de l'internet et des
services cellulaires sont depuis
longtemps dénoncés au canada pour régler
le problème
le chef du npd propose de calquer le
modèle australien
on a des autres entre pays comme
l'australie et tellement similaire comme
géographie comme population mais il paie
un moitié un pays endémiques que ce
qu'on dit mais s'inspirer de l'australie
dans ce domaine est à la fois une bonne
et une très mauvaise idée
pour ce qui est des cellulaires les
australiens sont nettement avantagé pour
un service qui coûte au canada 90
dollars par mois
les australiens vont payer 30 dollars
par mois et le réseau cellulaire en
australie est l'un des plus rapides dans
le monde
toutefois pour ce qui est de l'internet
haute vitesse résidentiel l'australie
est très loin d'être un bon exemple à
suivre
la haute vitesse en australie et l'une
des pires au monde à peine plus rapide
que l'internet au kazakhstan à 90
dollars par mois la haute vitesse
australienne est aussi cher qu'au canada
mais la bbc a déjà qualifié de ridicule
l'internet australien l'ancien premier
ministre du pays a qualifié le raison de
vrai désastre surtout les australiens
ils y ont englouti 46 milliards de
dollars en fonds publics